the little prince lives on his asteroid
b612 and he really likes to watch the
stars and what he really wishes for is
to watch the stars while floating to
have the best possible view and who just
immerse himself in the stars and so the
little prince has to think if there is a
position in space with respect to other
celestial bodies where the gravitational
force would just cancel so that he can
float let's look at that so there is the
planet of the businessman we're going to
give it the mass m1 and there is also
the small planet from the Lamplighter
floating around with mass m2 and we know
that gravitational forces act radially
so we can already see here that if we
put the asteroid b612 somewhere here
then maybe we find a constellation where
a gravitational forces cancel so let's
start by placing as the a little
asteroid over here and what is this body
experiencing in terms of the
gravitational forces well it's going to
experience a gravitational force of
object one so we have object one or f1m
due to the interaction between object
one store the business man planet and a
little asteroid here and then we also of
course have the same direction here due
to the interaction of object two and our
little asteroid so that would be F 2 m
and you can clearly see that if we tally
up these forces they are not going to
add to zero
so this is not a good location for the
little princess asteroid to be the same
would be true if we put it out here it
will experience those same forces again
what do we have here one M and two M
just going in the opposite direction but
you have guessed it already we can find
a spot here in the middle where one
force goes in this direction so this is
f2 m and actually we should give those
forces direction and the other body
exerts a force going in the other
direction and so we can say that we
don't now just need to find that exact
position here in between these two
objects with two different masses where
the little prince'
can freefloat while watching the stars
we can say already that if these two
masses were the same it would obviously
be in the middle but because of they are
not the same we have to calculate what
that distance is so we're going to label
this distance here X and we're going to
say that the two bodies here are a
distance D apart
alright how are we going to go about
this well we have to apply the universal
law of gravitation in our F equals MA
analysis well before we start with our F
equals MA analysis we actually have to
pick a coordinate origin and a unit
vector and so let's place the the
coordinate origin in here and let's have
I hat go in this direction and we're
going to label this here position a and
position B and position C these are our
three options for asteroid placement and
well let's look at position B
and well we have the universal law of
gravitation between the mass of the
object here and we'll have to describe
both components so first this one F 1 m
and then f 2 m and if we store it with f
1m that goes in the negative
I had direction so minus G M 1 on the
distance is x squared in the I hat
direction and then the other one goes in
the plus I hat direction and we have G 2
and now we have D minus X gives us this
portion d minus x squared also in the I
hat direction and
and that needs to add up to zero because
that is what we want right we want this
too if it adds up to zero then we have
no gravitational forces acting on the
asteroid so now we need to solve this
for X here and then the first step we
see that actually G and M will fall out
here and then we're left with M one over
x squared minus plus M two over D minus
x squared and we can write that as M two
x squared minus m1g minus x squared and
what you see here is that this will turn
into a quadratic equation and if we do a
few steps of arithmetic and then write
down the general solution to this
quadratic equation we will find this
here x equals to DM 1 plus minus 2 DM 1
squared minus 4 M 1 minus M 2
m1d squared and then the square root of
that over m1 minus m2 and actually we
need two of those so we have this
quadratic equation here while the
solution and we now need to consider one
more thing namely this equation here is
only valid if I can I write this here if
X is between 0 and D right if I and in
position C my X is larger than D which
means this sorry this force here flip
sign and then this would be different so
this plus here refers to X being less
than D and we have to decide which of
the two signs here give gives us the
correct which will fulfill this
requirement here so this simplifies to x
equals d m1 plus minus m1 m2 and here we
have the square root and then here we
have another bracket over m1 minus m2
and we need to get this term here
smaller than 1 or to be smaller than 1
if the x is between 0 and d and as it
turns out that is indeed true if we use
the minus sign here